then it's announced that you're going to
be a part of
indiana jones what was your reaction
when being a part of something as iconic
as indiana jones came up as a
possibility is it were you a fan of
those films was it something you were
excited about
i'm very very excited about it and i
know for a fact that uh
sitting here uh i think that's
maybe the film that wanted him to be a
become a director
and and i i rewatched the first one on
the raiders of the lost ark
it is so well done it's so charming and
it's
such great storytelling um so yes
it's it's obviously it's a it's a great
honor to be part of that the franchise
that we grew up with
did you get to read a script before
saying yes to that or is it
cast and james mangle that gets you
interested
no i mean no i did read a script
i i i'm in a lucky position where they
do
let me read the script before uh and yes
it was everything i wished it
to be is so so that was just great
when you do something like that do you
feel like you get to make a character
your own much like you do with a movie
like this
or is it very different the approach to
getting
you know embodying a character
yes i i do think that i i'm invited in
to create a character i think that that
everybody wants that uh that's why they
pick certain actors that they think they
can come up with certain things
uh and they will be a corporation as it
always is
but interesting enough again a little
like on a thumbnail on this one right as
a justice
that there is there is a kind of a genre
mix in indiana jones always there is
something that is a little larger than
live
uh characters uh almost back to the 30s
of of the
uh was to the law kind of feel and then
you have
indiana jones that that kind of is a
straight man
but but he also he he does produce a lot
of
funny and interesting things but but
there are different character genres in
some of those films
and and that is interesting to try to
find that balance
can you say anything about the character
you're playing in that or is that a
i can definitely do that but then you
will have to find me in a lake tomorrow
with some blocks on my feet you'll
suddenly get dragged out of the screen
that you're in exactly
doing something like fantastic beasts
where you
step into a role that had already been
originally played by somebody else is
that a different
approach for you as an actor to figure
out how to make that character your own
or are you figuring out how to build on
what was already done
nobody's interested in me going in there
and trying to copy anything
that would be creative suicide
immediately especially when it's been
done
before and mastered fully so so
everybody's expecting us to find a
different path
having said that we need a bridge
between what he did and what i'm going
to do so so those bridges we have to
find together
whether it's a certain look where
there's a certain attitude in certain
situations but
but you have to make it your own
anything else would be
plainly just creatively stupid what was
it that made you
want to do something like that because
it seems like an opportunity that
doesn't come along very often
yeah that that is one reason
and uh no i'm a big fan a fan of the
the party universe uh and
and it's a it's a it's a kind of genre
that yet you you don't touch upon in my
part of the world it's
it's just no go i mean you can't get
away with that budget wise it didn't
work
so obviously when it came my way was it
was just a fantastic opportunity